[Music]
hey tim
huh would you be down to name your uh
your newborn baby
uh interesting name just to get free
wi-fi for 18 years
what would you call them signal sit
this is to get free wi-fi for 18 years
no thank you
wait okay i don't hate twitter baby i
don't hate no no
there's an eye yeah yeah yeah i don't
hate that one sweet vs is a little
though
how fast is this internet a terabyte up
and terabyte down
i don't know yeah can you name the baby
tweef they're going to be called queef
yeah
exactly yeah well it doesn't sound a
male american english
or what is that what's this
it's only weird because it's a word
we've never seen before because when you
think about some names that exist
it's [ __ ] weird yeah no but they also
like like carol
what is that what the hell is gary
that's true what the [ __ ] is girl
the names that you've never heard before
that
are cool are the ones that always like
the letters and
they come together in a way that's
pleasant right what like
[ __ ] prize janae or something
well you know like there was some type
of um survey or focus group or something
where um
non-americans heard some american names
and everyone agreed that diarrhea
was really beautiful really and it is
just sound
you know what i mean and like so
basically like we don't we know
nothing but i don't know i can't pass
the meaning
it sounds like diana and then like
something real like diarrhea
in high school her last name was uh
areola oh beautiful and is that mario
it's like areola i'm gonna name my
twin daughters diarrhea and areola
i would rather be adeola than diarrhea
that's for sure
or canta canta
canta
[Laughter]
i like that
uh so this is a swiss internet provider
called
tweefy or twice with two feet oh
it's the name of the company the name of
the company i didn't get it right
so they offered 50 off they offered free
wi-fi for
18 years in exchange for naming a baby
in honor of their company
and so this one couple this one 30 year
old
and 35 year old couple who chose to be
anonymous they have actually named their
baby girl
tweefy tweefia twiffy first one is that
how you pronounce it because it's
t-w-i-f-i-a
maybe it's twi-fire right why is
switzerland known for their chocolate
tea food is very good right you can't
even grow
chocolate there though
sophia like fia tufia that's better
because it's really good
twiffey twiffy twiffy twinkie's kind of
cute for
baby girl
but they actually kind of cheated a
little bit because they just
named the their daughter their middle
name
oh well does the company know about that
does the wi-fi
no they did free wi-fi for nine years
yeah nine years
it was like shitty wi-fi it's like
spotty
yeah wi-fi they did give them uh they
are gonna
agree to give them free wi-fi for 18
years because they still
named like still technically part of the
name
middle name i might be down for right
right let's let's make it an american
company
verizon not so bad not bad charter
charter's kind of cool classic yeah they
already know what's talking
about wi-fi claritin
allergy
[Music]
oh i just switched to that by the way oh
fios is kind of fun
that's like greek that's some greek [ __ ]
yeah dude i would name my kid their
first name files that's kind of cool
dial-up fiosta
fiosa what's well what's another cable
company
spectrum that's the worst i don't know
about spectrum
that sounds a little time warner time
warner
frontier
i guess that's it there's not that many
we need to start an internet company
what if in america if any company
you can choose right and you can get
lifetime of this thing
if you name your kid that thing i'm
gonna buy my name i'm wrong
like you if you name a kid rolex or
whatever you get that's cute
coca-cola oh i'm not opposed to
and you get lifetime coca-cola products
how about this i'm in my kid house yeah
yeah yeah
well i'm naming my kids i need my kid
money or disney
if you could name your kid and then that
that company will be the lifetime like
they do like disney because they own
like [ __ ] everything
charming i would be pornhub do you pay
for it
no i don't actually yeah what am i
talking about because board help is free
yeah it is
what's something you actually pay for
well no no you can't pay for pornhub no
you can't but i'm saying
but for what the best content you have
to pay for what do we pay for that's
like such a drag oh
gas yeah chevron or just gas
one little gas mine is a i guess
what is that so cal edison edison's not
a bad name
yeah oh that actually is someone's name
right now but i know some edison first
name people oh a lot of chinese people
don't they pick that name
they love the yeah like edson
edison edison jk
news and you get 18 years of patreon
membership patreon's a fun name
patreon that's not just patron what name
do you actually like because i really
like the name for my kid
i really like the name kingsley is cute
he's a youtuber
is it too stuck up yeah oh yes
oh you know what kingsley i like bobo oh
no bubble king that's the name you guys
made up actually bobo kingsley is a fire
station coming to the stage bobo
kingsley
it's a that is a good stage in there
kingsley hi
yeah sure i think he would do that right
wearing nothing but overalls
with like a missing dude the first asian
hillbilly
i'm bobo bobo kingsley what are the some
of the names you guys are are you
chip i like chocolate chips not at
liberty though you can't talk about them
yeah what about some throwaway names
that you're like for sure in it yeah
maybe something you suggested and she
was like
no okay wait wait speaking of that do
you remember because we love
uh the tv show friends remember when
they were trying to name
uh ross and rachel's baby and they kept
vetoing and then phoebe was like
is it just being veto sound pretty good
as far as uncle vito names that i know
we're not gonna use like i always
thought
like um girls named after old presidents
were cool
like mad well madison is very abraham no
no no nixon kennedy kennedy i thought is
like a cute girl name
yeah or like donald oh yeah
lyndon lyndon you like lyndon linden's
not that
lyndon like lyndon b johnson yeah or or
like
let's see it was like madison eisenhower
oh yeah
bush here's little bush daughter bush
and um i thought like you know like uh
these these sounds so white girl names
now that
i sound them off but like uh months like
december or september i thought that
shit's cute
okay march if anything march
wednesday tuesday wednesday is cool i
like how about 41 42.
that's what i'm saying why not why stop
that why not midnight you know what i'm
saying i'm just gonna name my daughter
midnight
eleven's eleven's kind of fired eleven's
fire yeah
yeah why stop at months in like [ __ ]
days why not go you know what about
three three fifteen p.m p.m exactly
or like city names like boston oh i like
london
brooklyn i know a london i know i know a
kid named boston they call him boss
that's right yeah that's fun um
that's funny okay so my boy used to date
a girl name named bridget
and so i would always be like so puente
that's funny that's funny that's funny i
like eagle
eagle bomb oh
it's just an eagle eagle tiger
oh in what in like two or three
languages oh [ __ ]
mayori how do you say tiger in mandarin
oh and in shanghaines
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
but they're pretty you know they're
probably how do you say bicycle and thai
jackayan
is what the reference is yeah
rice krispie treat chinese rice krispie
treat
i don't know how do you say kebab elf oh
why
okay i need to know the train station
cause i know how to say that in
cantonese
[Laughter]
which husband is it i don't know is it
difficult to is it difficult choosing
names
[ __ ] yeah it was the hardest thing in
the world for me why because i think
it's something that you want to
you want to you have to commit to for
one and then you want something that
kind of like matches
who you think your kid might be or
whatever through all the different waves
so it can't just be something oh
a cute ass name but then like do you
want a 47 year old also with this cue
that yeah that's awesome
you gotta like so there's just a lot to
consider imagine a 45 year old dude and
his name is bubbles
that's a good sir but if you care about
their success you know then you gotta
write his name is boopy yeah booby
lilo and sticks wait i'll be honest it's
blurry for me too
i'm i think i've seen it remember he had
bubbles tattooed around
whoa spoiler alert
you know what's also interesting in
terms of names like a name might mean so
much to me but like you've known someone
with that name and you hate that name it
changes it that's why it's tough like
choosing it between two people true
because when uh i
i went to high school with some kid
named isaac and he was like some skater
punk he was kind of an [ __ ]
so i'm like [ __ ] i don't want to name my
kid after this [ __ ] so i'm like well
no he's he's my kid he's invented the
name yeah
the next kid i found a name
that it's genderless donuts
everyone loves donuts and they're sweet
but then they're going to be calling
them
and then back to d.o and then holistic
back to d.o yeah
[Music]
foreign